victoria a 19 ans et alexandre vingt ans
après le cégep en mode virtuel trois
sessions sur quatre leur nouvelle vie
d'adulte ne connaît que la pandémie
c'est beaucoup d'années qu'on a perdu
beaucoup de temps avec nos amis coréens
qui aurait été nécessaire c'est ben beau
faire des zooms même année
que lorsqu'on aussi la nouvelle en fin
de ce premier disque a annoncé qu'il
allait mettre un couvre-feu cas les
concerts tous fermés basse comme si
c'était notre l'ummc on touche quand on
vraiment que vous déposez sur nous
l'enclume au micro pour eux ça a été la
vague de trop s'en aller à l'école c'est
de nourrir ton laptop et de regarder des
corps à longueur de journée ce qui ne
sera pas de la maison te prie de routine
c'est comme si comme tout aucune énergie
cinétique en fait déjà trop de bruit car
l'un des gentils amitié si difficile je
pense que les manques d'échappatoire ça
l'est vraiment book créé
d'anxiété chez moi qu'est ce qui nous
reste en ce moment c'est juste le
travail et l'école et toutes les mêlées
plaisir les loisirs qu'on aimerait faire
mais on peut pas vraiment les effectuer
ils ont beau ne manquer de rien et est
requis et nantes oury ils se sentent
plus fragiles aujourd'hui
tout comme pierre luc labbé patron de 20
personnes
j'étais quelqu'un qui a toujours
travaillé sera niveau de pressions assez
élevées un trouble anxieux et était trop
ce qui m'était complètement étrange et
pourtant il a dû recourir un psychologue
pour l'aider à traverser les deux
dernières années les strass 1 dans notre
travail beaucoup augmenté tant au niveau
de gérer une entreprise mais de gérer
des humains aussi puis les endroits où
est-ce qu'on pourrait aller un petit peu
avoir une soupape pour pour relaxer un
peu on était quand même beaucoup limité
dans plusieurs que les symptômes
physiques de n'accepter sont tassées et
parents aussi qui jusqu'à une taille
pour aller au niveau de la peur puis
aussi un gros sentiment de culpabilité
que j'ai développée quand ça m'est
arrivé au début et j'ai dû aller
chercher de l'aide je me suis dit que si
j'étais quelqu'un qui n'avait pas les
moyens d'aller chercher ça je sais pas
qu'est ce qui me serait arrivé là c'est
quand même assez on devient quand même
assez en détresse dans d'épiques
d'anxiété qui doit pas être capable
d'aller chercher de l'aide très
immédiatement pour moi aurait pu
rappeler le plus grave de ce mouvement
carole mari elle est mère de trois ados
et chef de projet en informatique je
souffre de troubles anxieux depuis
plusieurs années donc gg des outils ge
mais là je suis vraiment arriver au bout
de mes ressources adaptative je sens que
j'ai beaucoup moins de résilience et je
sens que j'arrive plus à m'adapter à ce
qui m'est demandée alomar et julie donne
manquant quelques minutes je termine un
petit dossier puis je suis à toi il ya
quelque chose au fond de moi qui dis
mais à quoi bon tu rendait ma troisième
dose j'ai respecté tous les consignes
qui on est encore là on est le pays le
plus vacciner mais le plus confiné aussi
donc en fait je vous dirais que les
faits c'est cette espèce de sentiment de
résignation qui monte à l'intérieur de
moi qui provoque du cynisme qui provoque
le fait que je rêve en gris
la santé mentale selon elle a été trop
longtemps négligés dans cette crise je
sens qu'il ya des choses qui se mettent
en place à j'ai vu effectivement que les
restaurants à les réouvrir mais
si je me demande c'est pas un peu tard
six mois avec tous les outils que j'ai
réussi à développer à travers un suivi
psychiatrique psychologique je me sens
comme ça je n'ose pas imaginer comment
le commun des citoyens doit se sentir
consulter un psychologue ou un
psychiatre au québec est devenu très
difficile même au privé au public les
temps d'attentes peuvent aller jusqu'à
deux ans caroline thomassin girard et
pédopsychiatre oui là les attentats y
est très très longue
actuellement on adule asus parents on a
dû on ne peut plus accepter de nouveaux
patients parce que les délais étaient
trop longues d'une part et d'autre part
le phénomène qui se passe c'est que les
anciens patients reviennent beaucoup
aussi elle constate à quel point la
pandémie frappe les jeunes de 6 à 17 ans
ça a été beaucoup les troubles anxieux
beaucoup les troubles relationnels aussi
parce qu'un enfant fait d'ici là à
sortir de son milieu fait que on parle
la détresse des enfants ou des
adolescents mais les familles sont en
détresse les parents sont en détresse
les profits sont en détresse les fake
fait tout tout est fragilisée au tour
des jeunes donc il ya beaucoup d'enjeux
relationnel il faut briser leur
isolement dit elle lutter contre le
découragement est resté optimiste chez
goodyear cache pas inquiète j'ai le goût
de dire que je suis touché que ça me
fait beaucoup de peine de les voir
traversé toutes les épreuves le mais
j'ai le goût de dire aussi que je pense
qu'ils vont développer d'autres choses
tous rêvent de passer à autre chose pour
aller mieux les équipes de travail en
général au québec ont besoin de se
rassembler puis de retrouver une culture
d'entreprise et pouvoir travailler
ensemble je prends la lumière au bout du
tunnel je crois qu'on ne peut choisir
vieux port il ya un besoin fondamental
qui est nécessaire je pense que les gens
ont besoin de continuer à vivre je
trouve que maintenant il est temps qu'on
apprenne à vivre avec et qu'on apprenne
à assumer un certain niveau de risque
fabien aller mais c'est ça va faire